mais l'arrière bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors un
recours à 48 heures de la prise d'effet
du décret n'est ce pas trop tard pour
tik tok
non c'était trop tard c'est une façon
intelligente de gagner du temps ils vont
gagner une trentaine de jours ce qui
permettra peut-être à l'administration
américaine d'étudier la proposition de
la société de tik tok qui prévoit
notamment une structure faite sur mesure
pour les états unis avec des acteurs
américains dans la boucle et notamment
la société oracle et le géant des
supermarchés walmart
donc l'idée étant d'avoir un petit peu
l'équivalent d'une filiale américaine
qui serait co contrôlé par des
entreprises américaines pour rassurer
l'administration veut l'administration
de noël justement si donald trump soit à
interdire type qu'on peut le rappeler
c'était pour des raisons sécurité
nationale reprochant à l'entreprise de
donner des informations sur les
utilisateurs à pk est ce que c'est cette
accusation tient la route et est ce que
les propositions les nouvelles
propositions faites de la part de tik
tok pourrait remédier à ce problème
évidemment derrière toutes les
technologies il ya toujours une fission
et on ne peut pas dire à saint pourçain
qu'il n'y a pas de risque sécuritaire et
on voit d'ailleurs tous les jours sur de
nombreux sujets technologiques toujours
un risque que celui qui contrôle outil
puisse finalement mal utilisé les
données mais le vrai enjeu là c'était
pour donald trump en faire un argument
électoral
il a choisi à dessein la société tik tok
parce qu'elle est très populaire aux
états unis et l'idée étant de faire
parler et d'en faire un petit peu un un
exemple de son bras de fer qui l'a porté
pendant tout son mandat avec la chine
et donc voilà la société tik tok un
petit peu payé les pots cassés
sachant qu'il y a 5 millions
d'utilisateurs aux états unis
c'est tout simplement colossal et qu'il
y a eu des déserts des décisions de
justice en faveur de tik tok avant et
les les élections puisque les requérants
faisait valoir que tik tok permet aussi
c'est une plateforme qui permet la
liberté d'expression et la liberté
d'expression vous savez très protégé aux
états unis donc les arguments
d'administration trump face aux juges
vont pas forcément tenir la route
alors si jamais le décret prend effet de
masse qu'est ce que cela entraînerait
concrètement pour l'entreprise chinoise
concrètement elle devrait déférence et
des plateformes de téléchargement comme
l'apple store comme le plat store de
google donc les américains ne pourraient
plus la télécharger et donc déjà ce
serait un vrai obstacle pour pour pour
les gens qui peuvent vouloir l'utiliser
puis évidemment si les gens peuvent on
peut aussi couper le réseau et si on
coupe le réseau est bien tous les
américains qui utilisent des
applications tic toc pourrait se
retrouver avec une application sur leur
smartphone qui ne fonctionne pas alors
vous en parliez tout à l'heure la
société byden ça fait des propositions
alternatives pour le moment pas de
nouvelles pourquoi selon vous est-ce que
c'est lié à la situation électorale
juste avant vous nous disiez que donald
trump
on avait fait un argument électoral oui
alors le prises non trump avait fait un
argument électoral de son combat contre
cette société
donc le disait très populaire aux états
unis après je pense que dans les faits
ils n'avaient pas forcément beaucoup
enfin il n'avait pas très envie que la
situation soit décantée avant l'élection
américaine
il avait plutôt intérêt à faire monter
la pression est donc l mon avis ils ont
laissé le sujet de côté ils n'ont pas
étudié plus que ça les arguments puisque
pour eux c'était d'abord des arguments
électoraux
pour toujours montré donald trump en
champion quelque part du made in america
et du cou l'élection de joe biden est ce
qu'elles pourraient changer quelque
chose pour l'entreprise chinoise
oui je pense que ça va pacifier en tout
cas normaliser les relations avec la
chine
on va arriver à des discussions plus
apaisée entre les deux superpuissances
la chine aujourd'hui est vraiment un
forts compétiteurs pour les états unis
donc je ne pense pas que la pression
soit complètement relâché mais je pense
qu'on n'aura pas des bras de fer aussi
violent avec des entreprises qui
seraient pris à partie comme ça un petit
peu en mode otages
merci beaucoup yann malle arrière pour
votre éclairage je rappelle que vous
êtes avocat spécialiste du numérique